hey guys just a little over a week ago I
was able to be part of probably one of
the biggest international meetups of
coaster enthusiasts I've ever seen here
at wannabe Holland including but not
limited to coaster studios coaster kids
chat from Ohio Valley coasters and
coaster bots now the visit was part of
the European trip of the American group
which I got into because of coaster bots
but the fact that we got treated to a
very unique day at wannabe Holland was
largely thanks to micro Joe aka that for
coma guy who visits the park more than I
can keep up with and his insane ability
to know just about anyone who works at
or visits the park is crazy in any case
this program was really something
special certainly something I've never
experienced before
we've got early acces into the park of
one hour before opening time half an
hour of exclusive right time on the
flagship roller coaster Goliath
exclusive access to the backstage areas
and all of it was organized by the parks
event manager Scott all-in-all this was
definitely going to be a great day to
visit wanna be most of all I was really
excited to meet all of these youtubers
that I've known about and watched for
years finally in real life all in the
same place I guess you might even call
it a very ambitious crossover so without
further ado here's my vlog as a little
snapshot of what this day was like so we
just got into the park and we have
exclusive access nobody else has entered
the park yet except for our group of
American coaster enthusiasts and then
there's coaster bolts and a bunch of us
Dutch fans who are able to join this
trip and next we get an hour of
exclusive access into the park as well
as not an hour of ERT only Goliath and
the whole thing is led by Scott's the
event manager here who's an all-around
and who's showing us around the park so
yeah I am really looking forward to this
so this was a true backstage kind of
show over here we're skipping everything
to get straight on to the main streets
and currently we're making our way over
to a Goliath so we walked over to
Goliath walking through almost the
entire empty park for a total of six
rounds of exclusive right time on
Goliath only stopping every time to
switch into the park really small local
park without any rides we only had some
farms and some gardens where you can
hear cows and and see how that
experience was and still find that
experience today so now we yeah then
eventually it became wanna be played
well because
then six legs about the entire thing
they bought a lot of parts here in
Europe and especially a few years later
six let's show the entire thing
investment company and they brought the
name quality back and now we are in
Holland and it's going to stay sixty
four point eight meters in height it
goes 106 km/h I don't I know you guys
soon what and you get to enjoy it for a
half an hour
hello so this this is coaster boats
right here we're filming each other
filming each other that is peak youtuber
but we're currently getting a backstage
road through the park to get some kind
of shortcut to I believe it is loose
gravity yeah I think it's a good shot of
life oh yeah this I've never seen the
coaster from this perspective either so
yeah this is really cool we just came
off of ERT and Goliath six rides and
then they asked us hey you know we could
keep on doing ERT and Goliath or we can
get some ERT almost gravity as well so
we were all like hell yeah and hence we
get this backstage tour this is really
cool
also I'm just gonna plug coaster bot for
a second here if you don't know coaster
BOTS he's a British youtuber with a
golden silky voice who makes really
great YouTube videos about coasters
anything from like what is to vlogs as
well so definitely go subscribe to him
he's one of my favorite coaster channels
you're welcome here you can see it
running but unfortunately for us Express
platform 13 which is a clone of rock and
roller coaster but outside decided to be
down for the rest of the day and it only
opened again when we just left the park
that was a bit of a shame that said just
to slip my opinion in here because I
have been on this thing a few times
before I actually really like this
coaster perhaps even more so than lost
gravity which is a little bit of an
unpopular opinion but for me it's mostly
because of the launch which i think is
really great but the rest of the ride is
also quite smooth surprisingly so and I
think it's very fun normally you barely
get to see this coaster itself because
from the rest of the park it's really
hidden by foliage far away from the
paths but from this staff area that we
walked from we could see it really well
so almost everybody just stopped for a
while and to take pictures and videos of
the coasters it's really weird to see
these rights from an angle that you
never really see them from and the same
goes for a lot of these paths seeing the
entire theme park or empty is kind of a
surreal experience we were also able to
take pictures and videos off lost
gravity testing before the park opens
and we could pretty much just walk
wherever we wanted here for those who
don't know this coaster it's the first
and currently only build of mechs Big
Dipper model it has a really quirky
layout with inversions and snappy
elements but with very wide trains which
make it almost like a winged coaster or
dive coaster if anything I think is a
very unique experience and this ride
alone makes traveling to want to be
totally worth it if you're into coasters
and you happen to be around that said
unfortunately we couldn't ride it yet
because the park ran into some minor
issues with the brakes during testing
but since the EOT on lost gravity didn't
work out we're now getting in you're too
young Drako which is uh i guess that's
alright
that's a nice consolation price
after the other guys did a few biscuit
reviews loss gravity finally opened just
as the park opened to all guests so we
wrote loss craft team right away now
I've been on this thing before because
two years ago it was actually one of the
first inverting coasters I've ever been
on and I wrote it again a few times last
year so I already have a little bit of
an idea of what this thing is like so I
don't think I can do much of a first
time review that said I'm not a huge fan
of this vine I think it's a little bit
gimmicky and it seems that every year
it's getting more rough in a slightly
strange and shakey way still if there's
one thing that almost everybody agreed
on it's that that first half is amazing
and especially the first drop is really
fun how much you enjoy the rest I guess
kind of depends on your tolerance of
roughness speaking of rough coasters
after that we wrote Robin Hood the
Pyke's 4-koma wooden coaster now this
thing is notorious for being a little
bit shaky
maybe I'm enjoyably so but it's it's
definitely quite out there it's a wooden
coaster after all but it's it's mostly
famous because it'll get retracted into
an RMC hybrid coaster next year so this
might actually be my last ride on this
coaster and me together with Herman plan
and also Harry from we decided to hold
hands for the entire ride which was kind
of painful at some points but it was
actually kind of fun and it may be
usually kind of not so enjoyable
Robinhood a very fun ride
so I definitely recommend holding hands
with your friends winning on this ride
we continued our trip through the park
with a walk to speed of sound which is
the park's boomerang coaster and this
one is kind of special because it has a
tunnel on the lift hill and onboard
audio and even though the music isn't
really my taste I still think it's a
really fun and creative team and a nice
way to add something to the experience
of what would otherwise just be a short
back in for
the coaster it's not my favorite ride at
the park coaster wise but I always liked
the atmosphere in the intense backward
loop which makes it worth it if you're
there anyway I am filming him filming a
bouncing el Condor or as it should be
caught nowadays because that sign is
slightly outdated to just Condor is the
only ride I don't want to ride when I
might wanna be but I find myself riding
anyway because everybody does and it's a
little bit weird not to do it then but
this thing is the first of the suspended
looping coaster model which you can find
all over the world but almost all of
them are at least somewhat painful and
this one is certainly no exception I
absolutely hate this thing to be honest
it's intense but it's also really rough
it bangs your head around here and there
and it's just altogether not very
enjoyable if comfort is something you
highly value on a roller coaster like I
do
it's a shuffle it was one motored
waiting really plentiful
[Music]
at that point we are done
just about everything there is to do in
the park including a ride on the ferris
wheel which you see here so the Stafford
wannabe decided that let us do some
stuff that you normally never get to do
Taylor from kosu Studios was given a
staff outfit and he was allowed to
operate Goliath for a few rounds
pressing buttons and checking the
restraints while the rest of our group
skipped the entire queue just to ride
Goliath with Taylor operating it that
was really fun although I do feel a
little bit bad for some of the other
guests because we seriously held up the
queue for a while but I have to give a
lot of respect for wannabe for being so
flexible and willing to do just about
anything to give everyone a good time
and while we're at it I should probably
give a quick review of Goliath because
I've never done that kind of thing on my
channel but it's one of my favorite
coaches out there I think I'm a little
bit biased about it since this was
really one of the first major coasters
that I've ever been on but regardless
it's an amazing ride and definitely the
star attraction at the park at least for
me it has a great drawer amazing airtime
on the second hill and those small bunny
hops at the end of the ride might even
be my favorite part of this coaster I
think I personally prefer the mega Lites
model when it comes to the smaller mega
coasters like this but regardless
Goliath is one of my favorite coasters
out there and I don't think that'll
change anytime soon oh and as for these
shots of the coaster our entire group
was allowed into the staff only areas
underneath the ride just to take
pictures and videos of it which was
really cool so this is a slice of life
in the coaster kids and Cosi Studios
life Taylor is doing his gimbal stuff
over there as a review of Goliath right
there with the coaster kids and then
Harry's just kind of hanging out with
some Dutch dudes or something I think
and then there's a bunch of other dudes
as well there are a relevance don't say
that come on but uh yeah it's overall a
great time this is uh that is become my
boy doing his best dab right there
beautiful
10 out of 10 so yeah it's a great day
except for that piece of junk over there
in the distance
so now we're all of a sudden getting a
private tour of backstage behind wanna
be behind the Robin Hood roller coaster
right here so as you can see the Goliath
staff area was followed up by a small
backstage tour of Robin Hood which is a
slightly less exciting coaster to look
at perhaps but on the other hand it's a
really nice opportunity because you
barely get to see this coaster from the
rest of the park aside from that it's
interesting to see the layouts from up
close
given that the entire thing will be
reworked into an RMC hybrid coaster next
year at this point we can only guess
what the new layout is going to look
like but it'll probably follow the
already existing hills and have a
slightly higher but similar first lift
so one drop also from what I've heard
only two other visitor groups were ever
allowed into this area so we might as
well be the last visitors of the park to
see Robin Hood like this before it will
be converted next year which is pretty
cool so that just about runs it up for
my visits of wannabe Holland at least
for this video I've been trying to
wiggle my way into blocks from coaster
bolts and kosis studios as well let's
perhaps some other videos so I'll link
or tweet something about that when the
time comes anyway thank you for watching
guys and a huge thanks to coaster kids
coaster studios and ohio valley coasters
for doing this trip with fans across
europe
i'll link their channels down in the
description and as well of course thanks
to the staff at wannabe and aaron for
driving me all the way out there that's
all for now i'll see you next time
you